[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists ryan we all want
to be appreciated yeah accepted
acknowledged
but instead we are often misunderstood
and even offended
because of poor
communication in fact a lack of
communication is the biggest reason
friendships
businesses marriages and even our
personal goals
fail this week on the public podcast
we're talking about we're speaking with
vanessa van edwards
about
well
communication cues you know those tiny
little signals that we send through our
body language facial expressions and
word choices are vocal inflections
and then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast we'll discuss the power
of silence whether confidence and
charisma are innate the best way to have
tough conversations with co-workers
friends and family and how to create
meaningful connections that last you can
check that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
youtube channel and our podcast 100
advertisement free
because
advertisements suck yeah they do vanessa
thank you so much for being here oh
thanks for having me let's communicate
yes let's get into it yes
we're talking about communication cues
uh today your new book by the way is
called cues i'll hold it up if you're
watching the youtube channel thank you
we're gonna dive in to this book i
really enjoyed it i i enjoyed learning
more when i first picked it up i'm like
okay what can i possibly learn about
communication i'm clearly an expert
communicator
and then i learned very quickly like oh
i don't know anything about this
and uh i it really shined a light on
my understanding of what i do well what
i do horribly why i do some of these
things well other things that i could
improve significantly just through some
minor tweaks so ours is a listener
driven show i thought we'd dive into
some of our listener questions let's
start with uh catherine over on facebook
i feel chronically misunderstood like
i'm speaking a different language to
people how do i overcome this
oh my gosh i so relate to this so i
think that when we talk about cues we
don't realize that there's this hidden
language that's been spoken so we speak
our verbal language but actually when we
think about cues so cues are the social
signals we send to each other we are
sending hundreds if not thousands a day
the problem is we tend to focus all on
our verbal we think about the perfect
answer the perfect script we practice a
witty story and we wonder why we're not
getting a good date or why we're under
why we're misunderstood why we get a no
after we wish we had a yes so actually
there are four different channels for
cues
verbal
nonverbal so that's our body language
our facial expressions our gestures our
posture that's actually 60 to 90 percent
of our communication wow
60 to 90 percent
dirty just
just non-verbal oh wow okay just
non-verbal wow and then we have vocal
that's my favorite so that's how we say
our words our volume our pace our
cadence researchers find that we decide
how confident someone is within 500
milliseconds of hearing them
there's like hidden cues we can talk
about what those are why we think of
some voices as confident and some is not
and the last one is imagery so the
colors we wear
the fonts we use the props that we carry
so for this lovely question i think what
can happen is we're focusing too much on
one channel
we're thinking all about our words and
we think we have the perfect words we
don't know why they're not being adopted
the problem is if we don't have
congruence so if i were to come on the
podcast and say
i'm so happy to be here
[Applause]
so my word said one thing but there is
no way that you believe the verbal why
we give more weight to the other
channels and that's because it's harder
to lie with the other channels we know
it's easy to write the perfect to say
the perfect thing and so what we're
looking for the reason why i think
people are misunderstood and this was me
is that we're saying one thing but our
body is showing another we're saying one
thing but our vocal cues are saying
another so what i hear you saying is the
words we use is the least of the cues
yes that people are picking up on yes so
and and this is really hard because
especially now we're verbally
communicating more than ever
right our first impression is often our
linkedin profile we're chatting we're
texting we're slacking we're emailing
it's so much written communication that
we we trick ourselves into thinking
that's all that matters but actually now
more than ever we're listening for cues
we're looking for cues so i'll give a
really quick example on vocal because
vocal is my favorite so this 500
millisecond study blew my mind i was
like what like what are we listening for
so what can happen is when we're anxious
we hold our breath
and we speak at the top of our breath
and you can actually hear that that
sounds a little bit anxious
so what happens is people hop on a video
call or hop on a phone call or hop in a
pocket they say
hello
all the way up here
and that's really hard to listen to
and that is because we don't want to
catch the anxiety so the first aspect is
our cues are saying something to the
world our cues are telling the world how
they should treat us
but the second thing is your cues are
contagious
if you show up as slightly anxious as
slightly stressed and slightly fearful
you are sending those cues in your voice
your body your gesture and people are
catching them
so when i say
hello
all the way up here people go i don't
want to catch that anxiety i don't want
to listen to it versus if i speak on the
out breath so now i'm going to do the
opposite so really confident people they
relax their vocal cords and they speak
on the out breasts so here's anxious
hello
he's not anxious hello
same person sounds totally different
alabama she does a lot of voice over
work that's why we i'm not the only
reason we have her on the podcast it's a
very unfortunate opportunity for us to
have her on the podcast well show off
her talents but she could be anyone
because she understands these vocal cues
better
than just about anyone and
however if we're just using our words i
think it's one of the reasons getting
back to katherine's question we feel
misunderstood is sometimes we're using
the perfect words via a text message but
the other person is reading into them
differently yes now there's also it's
it's appropriate to say there are
different dialects that people speak as
well there's sort of a text message
dialect which is often different from if
i were writing an essay yes the dialect
and that is going to be different so
maybe you can talk about the different
ways in which we're misunderstood okay i
love it so
when we look at very highly charismatic
people and i'm i'm an awkward person i'm
a recovering awkward person so
you and me both right i think we
instantly bonded over that so i'm i get
social anxiety i'm super awkward i'm a
social overthinker so like i lay in bed
at night just like over playing
replaying every conversation in my head
which is why i learned cues as it helped
it helped calm me down um and so when i
was studying charismatic people research
is quite clear on this that highly
charismatic people what they are
signaling their cues are warmth and
competence
they are highly trustworthy highly warm
but at the very same time they're
capable and efficient and productive
so when we talk about words and being
misunderstood
even in a text message we are trying to
suss out someone's warmth and competence
so we did a study in our lab where we
had people come into our lab and by the
way we didn't warn them this was
happening so they were a little bit
surprised we had them take a warmth and
competence diagnostic so we figured out
where they were in warmth and competence
and then we asked to see their recent
text messages
and we counted the number of warm words
versus competent words
so warm words are things like whoop yay
fab wow
right emojis are highly warm exclamation
points are highly warm
and warm words also make you feel the
warm and fuzzies so they're like happy
best both together collaborate open
those are all warm words we like those
make us feel really good competent words
are wants to get it done that's a word
like productive efficient brainstorm
power through get ready push through
those word goal achieve master success
like when you hear those words you're
like yeah i want to get it done
and numbers graphs charts prices numbers
so we looked at their text messages and
we could predict
exactly where they fell on the charisma
scale based on the kind of verbal cues
they were using so what can happen is
you want to come across a certain way
right in a text message so you're using
all these verbal cues that you think are
coming across one way but actually if
you're using a ton of warmth you're
missing your competence
yes people aren't taking you seriously
so the problem is we're misunderstood
when we are too high there's an
imbalance in our warmth and competence
if someone's highly warm they're seen as
open and collaborative trustworthy but
not so smart not taken seriously
they're interrupted they're ignored
they're like oh i want to hang out with
you but i don't want your advice uh yeah
on the other side you have highly
competent folks and these are like
brilliant technical people who are using
lots of competence their ideas are
really solid they have really strong
ideas but without warmth they leave
people feeling suspicious and that's
actually right from the research that
highly competent people brilliant people
who don't have enough warmth leave
people doubting their competence
so they're coming across as super high
competence people say oh they're cold
they're intimidating yeah hard to talk
to
i can't i can't quite bond with them and
so they are misunderstood because
they're just sending an imbalance of
those cues so it's like yeah i want to
get it i want to get advice from you
i'll call you when i need a graph but
other than that like we probably won't
hang out too much smiley face yes
exactly yes exactly it's funny because
um
melbourne used to use like no
exclamation marks no emojis isn't it
funny we were around when emojis were
invented which is like oh i know we're
so old but anyways
i remember when like a trio was like the
coolest phone remember oh yeah the trio
yeah yeah the palm pilot trio oh yeah i
had like a little stylus and i'd be like
yeah i thought it was so cool oh it
still is cool wait no no no no
oh man so are you an emoji are you emoji
i'm definitely more emoji and he's
definitely more comp so i'm more warm
he's more competent yeah
in the book she she goes through like
these examples of like bert and ernie
and uh yes sherlock holmes
yeah yeah right warm competent pairs are
perfection you guys are the perfect oh
perfect keep going yeah it's perfect
i have a question for you so you're not
a huge emoji explained well he's changed
it over a while over time was it
physically painful for you to put those
exclamation points in yeah because i
believe in order
and it you know so i teach a writing
class and how to write better.org by the
way if you're interested but i um i
teach a writing class and often you know
what i talk to students about is if you
use the words that they do communicate
many of these things and so finding
precision in words however what i've
learned is that it's courteous to also
speak other people's dialogue there you
go and that dialect often includes
emojis so i'm not proactive with emojis
typically but if i'm interacting with
someone else who tends to use emojis
then it is polite it actually would be
rude if i didn't that's so funny so you
use emojis to be polite polite i use
emojis because i want people to
know that like i'm competent but hey i'm
not that competent
or take me take me seriously but don't
take me too seriously maybe that's a
better way or it's it's it's you saying
i want you to rely on me but i also want
you to like me yeah that's exactly it
yeah that's the name competence is about
reliance it's saying i can get what i
say done and you can rely on what i say
warmth is about i want you to like what
i say so i think that you have this
natural instinct which is i'm going to
add this emoji so that people rely on me
but also like me yes because what do we
want to do who do we want to be around
people who we rely and like a next level
tips you're doing an amazing precision
of word is my yes he is
so it's not only mirroring and matching
so if you're with someone who's highly
warm dialing up your exclamation point
styling up your emojis but next level is
mirroring the kind of emoji they do
right so this is like the advanced level
where if i see someone do a smiley face
with like a colon a dash and a
parenthesis you know what i'm saying
right i will do a colon of dash
parentheses but if i see someone who has
an equal sign in a parenthesis i'm going
to use an equal sign in french
my way of non-verbally respecting them
that's great right right and
it can come off though sometimes as
disingenuous if we are strictly
mirroring the other person sure so we
have to be careful with that so what
we're trying to do is we're trying to be
polite it's like if i know spanish and i
walk into a restaurant that speaks
spanish
and i don't speak spanish it's rude
right sure yeah now i may not be fluent
in spanish and so there would also be
rude if i just pretended that i started
saying some syllables that mimicked what
i heard yes i've made that mistake oh
dear yeah well you walk in you're like
hola you know
like and then they're like oh bien and
then they go into spanish i was like
that's all i know about spanish
and where's the bathroom and give me a
beer yeah and all i know is the laughing
crying emoji right
yeah
which is old right we're not supposed to
use that one anymore i don't i don't
know the rules but thankfully really
talk about no rules yeah
i know a young person said you don't use
that one anymore you don't use the
laughing and crying no that's too old i
was told by a gen zier and i was like
okay
let's turn into our gen zers over here
alabama
yeah danny danny's a gen z yeah
yeah he's saying he's saying no yeah we
have his approval so i i like the the
emoji with the little um
like
gla you know what spyglass what is this
thing yeah you mean the pretentious
emoji no no it's just kidding the mr
peanut emoji you're thinking that's like
that i have an eyeglass yeah cuz like
when am i ever gonna have an eyeglass
but my emoji can oh we've gotten real
off track guys well my wife will start
with me by sending me the devil emoji
yeah the little purple devil with the
horns like naughty yeah
yeah i think we just learned a lot about
you
kathryn thanks for your question
has a question from patreon how can you
tell whether a person clearly isn't
listening to you and is just generating
their rebuttal while you are still
speaking
oh man okay so let's talk about how we
process so remember that when we're with
someone we're sending hundreds of these
cues back and forth so our brain is
processing a lot it's processing the
verbal information it's trying to suss
out non-verbal it's trying to listen for
vocal cues and of course you're trying
to think of your great answer so you
know that someone's processing what you
are saying if they're trying to take in
your cues if they're making eye contact
or they're looking at body language if
they're looking at gestures that means
they're trying to process all the cues
being sent to them when someone is
processing something else we typically
look up and away so for example we do a
little experiment right now you want to
do some math sure sure ready yeah okay
uh 10 times 10 yeah plus 40
minus six
divided by okay so you're looking up
yeah i automatically go look that's
where my calculator is right your
calculator is up so most people's
calculator i don't know the answer do
you know the answer to that i i lost yet
divided by 4. 134.
[Laughter]
so so far you sound like you're going to
keep going no i was just i was just
trying to see if you were going to look
away because
when people ask people to process
something complicated they will almost
always look away yeah and that is
because socializing if we're making eye
contact we're producing oxytocin and so
our bodies focus on connection if i ask
you a hard intellectual question your
brain goes stop connecting and try to
think of the answer
so you know when someone is not
listening to you if they are looking up
or away they're probably trying to
process some answer they're coming up
with that makes sense you know i do i
look away like right now i'm looking
away when i'm trying to like gather a
thought yes if i'm looking at someone's
cues it distracts from the train of
thought that i have so i often like when
i'm have something to say i'm not
looking yes at someone now when i'm
trying to be genuine i'll look at
someone in the eye like i go out of my
way to be like hey this is me i want you
to see me i don't want you to hear me
yeah but yeah when i'm trying to process
a thought like i'm always looking away
so if we talk about eye contact for a
second i think there's a misconception
there's two misconceptions about eye
contact that i would love to bust if we
can bust them out good because i have
trouble with icon oh do you serious
trouble what's your trouble i just can't
talk to someone and also maintain eye
contact
okay okay so that is because when the
reason we make eye contact as humans is
because we're trying to make oxytocin
oxytocin does a lot of things in our
body so just simplified for us it's the
chemical of connection it's what makes
us feel like um i really like this
person oh my god that's how i felt when
i was on pain pills it makes so much
sense
yes and they also give oxytocin to women
in labor oh okay interesting like in
intense doses it's like the ultimate
kind of the ultimate man like we are
just like we're vibing aren't we yeah
exactly yes yeah so when you're like on
the same page with someone when you're
clicking with someone that's asking
oxytocin and our body is smart enough it
goes
if we're close enough to make eye
contact i guess i better produce
oxytocin so we produce chemical that
chemical the problem is it makes it very
hard to think
so when we're making eye contact our
bodies like okay oxytocin oxytocin that
makes us feel connected but it's really
hard to then think of what your point is
what you're processing so actually the
sweet spot for eye contact is not a
hundred percent and that is a myth so
many people are told make a hundred
percent eye contact yeah but then you
look like oh show you
it's so creepy
and so that's creepy so actually don't
go after 100
you should let yourself process that
actually makes you a much better
conversationalist the sweet spot is
about 60 to 70 of your conversation you
should be making eye contact okay yeah
have you heard about terry gross that
she she does fresh air the radio show i
know she even when she brings someone in
studio they're in separate studios
because she feels as though she can't
think yes and therefore it degrades the
product she's creating so
they'll be in the next room over there
you we've done these sort of radio
interviews where
it's remote but even when you're in
person with her you're remotely remote
yeah and it's because i think the eye
contact probably screws her up a bit and
that's okay so i think that what we have
to realize is if you're pitching or
you're presenting a really important
idea and you want to really deliver
don't worry about the eye contact i
would rather you focus on wherever you
want to look to get your point out there
the eye contact is less important if
you're on a date you're trying to bond
okay that's when eye contact is far more
important than whatever spiel you're
coming up with in your head so you can
kind of prioritize where it is the
second myth about eye contact is i don't
know how but a couple years ago there
was some article that came out that when
you look up the left you're lying yeah
when you look up to the right you're
remembering or something like that yeah
i remember this yes okay and everyone no
i must lie a lot exactly there's no
research to prove it so what happens is
people read that silly article and then
when you're processing people will he
must be lying right yeah it is just
processing there's a lot of line cues we
could talk about but that's not one of
them yeah i i forgot i forget when i
read that article but i remember it was
you know a week two weeks two months
whatever like i was like don't do this
up into the left thing and then what
just would screw me up even more when
i'm talking to someone yeah
close your eyes
all right um welcome to the podcast with
us now in the book you actually talk
about uh rbf resting oh yeah bothered
face as you call it
okay so resting bothered face i have
this affliction does anyone else have
this my wife does
call her out on it
no she knows she doesn't and in fact she
uh she's the one who brought up to me
and i'm like
i don't know i love her so much it's
almost as though i don't see it yeah but
she has mentioned how like sometimes she
doesn't realize how that can come off to
other people and you talk about there
being three components anger sadness
contempt can we talk about that again
yes okay so what we're talking about is
how our face some universal facial
expressions so our face has over ten
thousand different muscles our face and
neck so there's a lot of different
facial expressions that we can make but
what dr paul ekman has found is that
there's some universal expressions
across cultures so let's talk about
anger so anger we're really angry we
pull our eyebrows down so these two
vertical lines appear we harden our
lower lids and we often tense our lips
or our jaw
so when that happens that shows that
they've actually shown that that anger
face makes us look stronger like it
makes our jaw puff out and it makes our
forehead go down which makes us look
stronger that's why we make that face
wow okay so at resting resting bothered
face is when people at rest are
accidentally activating the anger
muscles so when people are concentrating
and they're accidentally activating
those eyebrows and hardening their lower
lids because they're concentrating it
looks a little bit like anger and people
think oh she's really irritated right
so two choices here one is you should be
aware of what your resting face looks
like are you resting with these with
your eyebrows hardened are you resting
with your jaw clenched it might be
accidentally signaling anger
what you can do is tell people that hey
i'm not angry that's just my resting
face right right the other option you
have and this is i'm gonna give a crazy
option here there is some research that
has found that anger management can be
changed with botox
that people are botoxing this part of
their face because it actually makes
them feel less angry and makes them look
look less angry oh wow i've been looking
for a reason to get botox
resting bothered face
i'm not actually recommending botox but
i just i share that as an example of
that you can also focus on relaxing that
part of your face i wonder if like
facial exercises or something could like
oh i'm sure that facial yoga could do it
yeah so i have resting sadness face so
sadness i know and people always think
i'm down or sad
or wrong
people say are you okay
look i'm fine it's just my face
[Laughter]
it's not me it's my face that's
literally what i say and then everyone
laughs and it's totally fine so sadness
is one of the universal expressions
sadness is a down expression it's when
your whole face goes down so your um the
corners of your lips point down into a
frown so real sadness your lower lip
puffs out and you pull your mouth down
to a frown if you try you'll actually
begin to feel sad
almost impossible to feel joy in that
expression so my the corners of my mouth
point downward just at rest
so because of that it looks more like a
frown and also my eyelids slant
downwards that's why i use uh eyeliner i
don't know if you can see it looks great
it makes it go up because otherwise i
look sad so this is a really important
note about yourself because then you can
see what are people defaulting to you on
a video call on a phone call what do you
look like when you're listening right so
i work extra hard on video calls to say
oh i'm super into it i use warmth cues i
use nodding to make up for the fact that
i know i have a resting sad face
now i will say this
getting back to aiden's question here
knowing there are two ways that i tend
to know that someone is not paying
attention to me they're not listening to
what i'm saying the first thing is
they're on their phone
well that's a good one and it happens
all the time way more frequently now did
you see the visual cue he just gave me
yeah
and the second one is their phone is on
the table between us 100 and what that
does it puts up a force field between me
and them and what it's saying is you're
the most important person to me in the
room
unless anyone else comes and interrupts
me digitally
and then you're the least important so
this is fubbing right it's called
fubbing it's like phone snubbing can i
give you a little my favorite tip so i
also do not like to be fubbed i don't
like when someone's on their phone so
what i do so there's two little tips
little cues you can use if you don't if
you're being fubbed so the first is if
someone checks their phone stop talking
and look at their phone
as if you want to check it too
and you can literally even say all good
yeah yeah yeah oh wait yeah that's what
josh usually tells me he's like oh oh
wait man yeah i'll wait yeah it's
usually when i have my phone out and i'm
in the middle of something and he starts
to talk to me and i'm like okay like let
me finish this one thing yeah yeah yeah
but that's okay yes okay so look at it
look at the phone stop talking and say
all good yeah i'm good yeah the other
thing can happen is people look over
your head so the other way that to
answer the question you know someone's
not listening to if they're overhead
gazing so they're looking around the
restaurant around their party to see if
they're someone better to talk to oh wow
that's probably my most
like annoying or most biggest pet peeve
when it comes to someone not paying
attention to me like they're looking
everywhere buddy but you yeah okay so
that means that their brain is kind of
scoping the room so here's what i want
you to do if that ever happens to you if
someone begins to overhead gaze with you
i want you to turn around and look
yes oh wow
yes and every time they do it look
baffled and then just look
yeah like what's yeah because they don't
realize that they're doing it to you
they think you're not noticing
so if you turn around and look behind
you you're literally saying
okay we're not here if we're over there
let's do it together yeah
okay i tell you one that ryan does to me
i think he doesn't realize it probably
not i only realize because we're such
close friends i think most people are
you scared what he's gonna say no he's
okay
so
if i could tell he's not paying
attention if he says yeah about
four times in a row no no if you say it
about
i don't know
one tenth of a second too soon or two
tens three tenths of a second too soon i
could tell you he's just doing yeah
right there that was a genuine yeah yeah
but like no
yeah yeah there are other times where
he's like there's something else going
on here yeah yeah and it's to like it's
almost as though hurry up or it is i got
it
right that's exactly what it is i got it
that's what it is it's but the thing is
he doesn't got it
well i have this problem and this is a
me thing and you're right i pro probably
the majority of the time don't get it
but my brain my add brain is like
um you can stop talking right now we do
not need to waste any more words like i
understand what you're saying and i
would i would maybe it's 50 50. but yeah
you're right sometimes i say yeah and
it's like okay maybe i don't get it i do
the same thing to mariah so don't feel
bad i don't in fact i used to think it
was a ryan problem but now i realize
it's a me problem here's why i say that
it's a prison for me to need him to
listen to me
i've put myself in a prison i need my
expectation is he will listen to me no
matter what well no why why do i deserve
that no it's the truth is that he
listens to me if i have something
compelling enough for him to listen to
if i'm not compelling enough then i
might get the half a second early yeah
the dismissive yeah as a result okay so
can we talk about some of the cues here
all right so what we like as humans are
vocalizations that's what it's called
there's a difference between a yeah and
a vocalization so vocalization is
uh-huh
yeah
we love that right
our brain goes oh they want me to keep
going those are invitation cues like
their invitations really going when
someone says yeah
we know ah they've got it be done so
there's that slight difference and what
i don't know if you noticed when you
were
imitating
that yeah you also did a very fast nod
so often times a yeah or i got it is
partner with a very fast nod so we we
just happen to do that because what
you're saying is um i got it i'm taken
care of it's it's done so a nodding is a
universal warmth cue a slow nod means
tell me more
they found that when peop someone triple
nods a slow triple nod the other person
speaks 67 percent longer
so when you both gift me triple nods i
speak longer that's awesome but when
someone does a fast nod it means be
quiet i'm done so watch the difference
okay so if you want someone to keep
talking on your show do a slow triple
mod if you want them to be done and wrap
it up give them a fast one so here's the
difference uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh versus
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh yeah i'm feeling
epileptic right now
how do i
because now
i'm not because we're not conscious of
all of these cues right it can be right
and we can be but it's like you opened
up a door i did and i lived in the
soviet republic for so long and now i'm
in a whole foods and i'm like
overwhelmed by all of these cues that
are everywhere around me i love that
metaphor or like i say it's going from
um standard definition to hd
yes yeah i feel all of a sudden you can
see the pores you're like wow
or you take that knowledge even farther
with wizard of oz the black and white to
full color all of a sudden and now i see
all these things and it's going to take
a while to adapt but as i was reading
the book and you're asking questions
about confidence and and you're talking
about this that you have a chart in
there in fact of like the the confidence
that you want competence yeah
and um what i realized is that oh yeah i
do many of these things sort of
naturally or i've been acculturated to
do these things and there are other
things that i've almost like kept at
arm's length that would improve my
communication skills as a result and
this is why this uh this question to me
aiden's question uh about listening and
on the maximum episode we have another
question about listening but the other
way like hey it's really hard for me to
listen to other people and so we're
going to talk about that a bit on the
maximum i do want to move on to our
callers here aidan thanks for your
question thanks for being a patreon
supporter by the way
or callers if you have a question give
us a call 406-219-7839
or email a voice memo to podcasts at
theminimalists.com we have a question
here today from karia in
berlin germany i'm still on my teams and
live with my parents and
they have lots and lots of stuff so
there is a big contrast between their
approach and mine and
recently i think
they
seem to think i'm being too radical i
guess um because i've made some
changes i let go of so much stuff that i
could get rid of an entire shelf in my
room i also had a palette bed before
didn't like it so
now i'm sleeping on the floor and just
to kind of see how it goes and
there's a lot of tension
because i feel unwell um
since i'm forced to
hold on to lots of things for school and
because there's a big closet in my room
which i share with my mom
and
they also are talking about
giving me
things that i don't want when i move out
next year
so like decorations and tableware and
everything and
i
don't really know how to deal with my
family
and find out what's working for me at
the same time
because they just don't seem to get that
i
don't want to have
as much
stuff as
they might so
yeah i don't really know how to
deal with that
so vanessa this really does seem
fundamentally like a communication
problem i know it's a it's really a
communication problem that is disguised
as a stuff problem yeah we're the
minimalist we often talk about letting
go of stuff i wanted to discuss with you
though the opening line to your book i
think
is a question that addresses this so the
open line to cues is have you ever
shared a great idea only to find that
others didn't get it
and
where we are with korea right now is
she has a great idea or something she
perceived to be a great idea and her
parents just don't understand
okay so i think this has to do with a
very fundamental personality trait
called openness
so when we look at personality science
one of the best research some of the
best research we have is that everyone
across genders and cultures and races
has this trait called openness and
people who are high in openness they
crave new they crave change they're very
comfortable with change in fact they're
more wired for dopamine response
pleasure response when they try
something new so for high open people
they're like yeah try something
experiment do it for low open people
they're about habit routine and
tradition
so low open people have less dopamine
response less chemical reward when
something new happens
so for this caller i love it because she
is probably i'm guessing much higher in
openness she's trying something new she
wants to see how it goes she's not sure
she's still figuring out the line that
she said was i don't know how to deal
with them while i'm still figuring it
out
so here's what we have to understand is
if you're talking to a low open person
you talking about new things is going to
stress them out
amen right you're actually triggering
their fear a low open person will say
things like if it ain't broke don't fix
it
why fix something that works for me
whereas a high open person thinks if
there's something new maybe i'll
discover something so here's what you
should do from a communication
perspective if you are a high open
talking to a low open you want to
actually start with what isn't changing
for a low open person they want to make
sure you're still you
they want to make sure there's still
some sort of habit retreating so i think
that there was briefly mentioned of the
holidays right like have decorations
okay so here's how i would talk to
parents who are low open hey i am so
excited for the holidays coming up i
can't wait to have our beautiful dinner
i can't wait to have everyone get
together i love that tradition i am
going to be trying something a little
different and we always minimize the
change a little different you know i'm
actually not going to do decorations
this year my favorite part of the
holiday is actually the dinner and the
camaraderie and the singing and the
sharing the decorations don't really
matter so for me i'm just going to take
away that little piece of this tradition
and and maintain the stuff that really
matters
as opposed to
a high open person you'd pitch the
opposite so if you had a high open
parent you'd say guess what
i want to try something new
this is totally different this is
totally radical i'm doing a minimalist
experiment
so here's what i want to do this holiday
this holiday we're going to go
decoration free we're going to see what
happens with a decoration-free holiday
will it still feel the same will you do
the experiment with me
two totally different approaches to the
same kind of thing
that's beautiful that is awesome yeah
that's that's awesome and by the way
this works also in business too so i
think it's really important if you're if
you're pitching an idea you have to
think about the receiver right like it's
not just how you pitch the idea it's how
are they going to best receive this idea
so if you're in business and you know
that you want to pitch let's say a
client on a new piece of software
or a boss on a new idea for the company
a low open person you want to start with
what isn't changing
right for a low open boss they don't
want to hear the new they want to hear
what isn't changing what is going to be
easy and then if you're going to have a
change you want to say here's how small
it is but here's the impact it's going
to have so for a low open in business
you're pitching impact impact impact
social proof and routine
for a high open boss you're talking
about the bells and whistles the razzle
dazzle the new that it's a new
experiment a new project it could change
everything
those are totally different ways to
approach the same kind of idea i love it
if i had like a pithy answer for uh
korea here it would be
to be
understood by others you must understand
others that's it and that's really what
you're giving her advice on is hey show
your parents like meet them where
they're at and here's how you meet them
where they're at and and minimize the
change right the change is she's not
saying that i'm a different person
right she's not saying i don't love you
she's not saying rock i'm really sure
she's just saying the way that she's
living is gonna be a little different
right and so honoring what isn't
changing can have actually a way to make
them feel better i think like the golden
rule versus the platinum role have you
heard this metaphor
you know like the golden rule treat
others the way they would the way that
you would want to be treated actually
don't love the golden rule i like the
platinum role the platinum rules treat
others the way they would want to be
treated yeah yeah i think that's more
powerful yeah because ultimately that is
a golden rule rule because i want to be
treated the way i want to be treated
right exactly so we're right back to it
yeah
thanks for your question we're gonna
send you a copy of vanessa's book it's
called cues also i'd love for you to
download our free minimalist rule book
over at theminimalists.com
resources it's there on our resources
page there are 16 rules for living with
less but they're not real rules they're
boundaries so one of the ways that we
can help communicate with other people
is by being loving with our boundaries
setting up boundaries well the only way
you can do that is if you know what your
boundaries are and so we provide some
boundaries in there for you as well it's
the minimalist rule book 16 rules for
living with less over at the
minimalists.com ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions you can text your comments you
can text your emojis to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now vanessa
during the lightning round this is where
ryan and i and our guests we do our best
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
i'm not great
you can monitor on a bit it's like a rap
battle vanessa okay okay great
what podcast sean does is he tweezes out
something pithy and beautiful he puts it
in the show notes so people can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if they like and now you can find all of
our minimal maxims in one place it's
minimalmaxims.com k has a question for
us
why does non-verbal communication carry
so much weight
short right
okay it's hard to lie with our nonverbal
we're very rehearsed at saying lies with
our words but it's really hard to lie
with our gestures our face our posture
and so we believe it because it's
usually more true um yeah
yeah that is pithy that's good here i i
took an old saying and and played around
with it in fact made fun of the little
bromide here
simple actions speak louder than bland
natterings
as an introvert a person who
has been social distancing way before it
was cool
i
i don't like small talk i don't like
bland natterings right
and and so i avoid people blind matter
is a memoir by joshua fields millburn i
actually have this written down
it's a line from love people use things
so
about how i didn't feel compelled to
fill the air with bland natterings
and
i think though what we do with that
silence we'll be talking a bit more
about silence on the maximal episode
sometimes just because we're not
speaking we're still saying a lot which
brings us to your pithy answer oh man i
had such a hard time with this so like
uh because all i could think of was the
actions speak louder than words and i
could not get that out of my head
so um i got three i got three put the
answers ready one is um
actions talk
words bulk
so that's kind of like my take on the
bromide um i was talking to mariah about
it this morning here's what she helped
me come up with uh the body speaks the
truth
even when the mouth can't
i was like oh that's good and then
melbourne help me come up with this one
everything we say
involves everything we don't say
hmm
so podcast sean you pick your favorite
listeners you pick your favorite but i
was
i could not get the action speak louder
than words out of my head and i just
like kept coming at it so um so now you
know my writing process when it comes to
these
i go to myself i go to mariah and i go
to josh
you can all say gestures speak
words lie
oh yeah
i should have got a hold of vanessa
we got so much more to talk about but
first alabama what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hey there this is anna from minnesota
and i have a tip for anyone getting
married that doesn't need a bunch of
household gifts i'm currently planning
my own wedding and was kind of dreading
the registry process until i found out
about a website called honey fund this
website allows couples to register for
honeymoon expenses such as hotels
flights and all the fun stuff
like wine or beer tours or parasailing
you can customize it however you'd like
and your loved ones can pay for parts of
your honeymoon right on the site through
paypal account it's a very easy process
for both the couple and the guests and
it's taken a lot of stress out of our
own wedding planning process
hey josh and ryan this is helen from old
town maine
i'm one of those people that absolutely
hates putting something in the garbage
that still has life in it just because
no one has a need for it
old torn up clothes included this month
i'm going to the a developing country on
a christian medical mission trip what
i've been doing is i've been taking some
old jeans that i no longer use with
really tattered bottoms cutting them
capri length and using the denim to make
hackies act
i then hem the capris so they don't look
tattered i'm planning to bring the hacky
facts down with me as a group game that
will be a gift for some of the kiddos we
help out and i can wear the capris while
i'm down there and then leave them for
someone who needs them after i'm done
using them
this way perfectly good jeans are not
ending up in a landfill i'm getting rid
of excess stuff someone gets a pair of
capris and a whole bunch of kids that
don't have money for or access to toys
will get um hacky sacks to play with
it's a win all around
all right y'all big thanks to our guest
today vanessa van edwards her new book
i'm holding up if you're watching on
youtube it's called cues now you can
also check out her youtube channel we'll
put a link to that in the show notes
where she breaks down different social
cues and communication cues with famous
actors and actresses and different
famous people we'll put a link to her
youtube channel also her website is
called science scienceofpeople.com
ryan real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist actually
something that just happened you and i
went to a matt carney concert
recently it was so good man uh ames
hotel is that what it's called it's the
ace hotel ace hotel yeah ace hotel what
a what a beautiful venue like it was
this weird balance of like uh i don't
know man venetian but art deco like it
was it was cool it was a beautiful venue
and great concert have you ever stayed
at an ace hotel before no they're
they're stunning there's only maybe i
don't know a dozen or two dozen of them
there's one out in palm springs
there's uh one in portland that we use
there's a coffee shop in there there's
stuff down there yeah we'd always hang
out in but ace hotel they they curate
this aesthetic that is beautiful but
also comfortable it's
not super stark although it's relatively
minimalist yeah and the theater at the
ace hotel downtown where we saw matt
carney what a great concert and the
national parks opened up for him oh yeah
and what a beautiful surprise that was
yeah at first i saw the sign i thought
it said the national was opening which
didn't make anything like wait a minute
holy moly but it was it was just as good
i mean i really enjoy the opener i hate
when i go to a concert now now i'm
learning something i want to have a
future conversation about this about
aging out of things because i think i'm
beginning to age out of concerts i hate
to admit getting older but yeah man i'm
with you there's certain things i'm
majoring out on too what i'll tell you
ryan is that
it's not that i don't enjoy the concert
it's i don't enjoy all the pomp and
circumstance around the concert before
remember when we lived in dayton and we
wanted to go to a concert and say
indianapolis oh yeah we'd plan a whole
day around oh yeah get up there early
two-hour drive yeah get be the first in
line get good seats yes stand there and
what even good seats quite often we were
just standing close to the stage
and it's a whole 12 hour process from
the drive there to the drive home and
the standing in line and everything else
and now i just don't seem to have the
same
joy of the entire process anyway we'll
talk about that in the future episode
because i want to talk about aging out
of certain things growing out of i mean
we all do it
we're kids we grow out of our toys
we become pubescent and but then i think
as adults we begin to grow out of
certain relationships or grow out of
other things as well so i want to talk
about that i want to encourage our
listeners to go back uh speaking of matt
carney we did a quarantine conversation
or i did a quarantine conversation with
him it was actually our last one of
2020. so in 2020 ryan during the whole
quarantine thing we did 50 you and i 50
different quarantine conversations where
we called up different artists friends
musicians different people and we just
had random conversations with them some
of them were eight minutes long some of
them like the macaroni one i think 45
minutes long you can find all 50 of
those over at patreon.com
the minimalists for our added value this
week ryan oh by the way matt carney on
that quarantine conversation that is
where he announced
the
title for his album yeah how cool was
that january flower and we saw him on
the january flower
tour
and
he that was the very first place where
he talked about these i haven't told
this anywhere i'm like do you want to
announce it here he goes yeah i guess so
that's great so you can check that out
patreon.com
the minimalist we had a great
conversation in fact i talked to him i
said you were drake before drake
because he was singing also doing the
spoken word stuff yeah he's like oh my
god can i put that on a t-shirt
i'm like yeah man you own it you were
definitely drake before drake for added
value this week ryan speaking of matt
carney we're at the concert in between
every song you kept yelling out play
girl america not every single
between songs but most of them yes you
kept throwing panties at him where did
you get all the panties
none of your business
i'm a minimalist his first album is
called nothing left to lose and one of
our favorite songs which he didn't play
although he played a bunch of amazing
songs at that concert it's hard for him
it's got to be so hard because he's got
like five or six albums
in every single one of those albums he
could just play the whole album at a
concert and you'd feel satisfied yeah
but you were unsatisfied so i'm gonna
satisfy you right now ryan hey thanks
here is girl america from matt carney
from his first album which is called
nothing left to lose by the way ryan we
got a bunch more surprise questions this
week like i have a terrible habit of
interrupting others without meaning to
what can i do to break the habit
if we were forced to see debbie downers
every day at work how can we communicate
with them without letting them bring us
down
when there is conflict i get so stressed
that i just want to leave the room how
can i show confidence in these
situations when walking away isn't an
option plus we got a million more
questions for vanessa and the minimalist
you don't want to miss that if you want
to check it out theminimalists.com
patreon or patreon.com the minimalist
you can check out our private podcast
this week every thursday we do a private
podcast for you you'll subscribe you get
a personal link so that our weekly
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain immediate
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalists on tick-tock instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalists
if you want our podcast show notes in
your inbox thanks to our good friend
podcast sean he curates all of them
all of those show notes they'll show up
right in your inbox just sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll enter your
email address at the top we'll never
send you spam junk or advertisements but
we will send you our simple sunday
emails whenever we send those as well on
behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast shawn
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown p3 emma the immigrant and the
rest of our team i'm joshua fields
milburn reminding you to
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it